je suis franco allemande je suis
vraiment né en allemagne de parents
allemands mais qu'il n'ait d'occasion
allemande une formation allemande et
aujourd'hui je suis députée française à
l'assemblée nationale c'est quelque
chose si on l'avait dit à quelques
années que je dis c'est absolument
impossible
quand je suis arrivé en france est à 38
ans ça n'aurait pas pu être possible
j'ai posé donc un français et pour nous
deux familles ça n'a pas été évident
quand moi j'ai annoncé à ma famille que
j'allais poser un français et mon mari
j'épouse une allemande s'était pas des
sauts de joie parce que nos deux
familles ont perdu des membres très
proche à la première guerre mondiale
quelques années à après ces gens là se
trouve une table de mariage à chanter
ensemble à faire la fête et à s'entendre
c'est pas par hasard si aujourd'hui je
me retrouve dans l'assemblée
parlementaire franco allemande j'ai
toujours eu un lien très fort avec
l'allemagne j'avais un grand père qui
avait fait la guerre 14 comme tous les
grands pères de cette génération et à la
fin de sa vie en 1965 j'étais en
allemagne un séjour dans une famille en
train d'apprendre allemand il m'a reçu
une lettre comme un testament où il m'a
dit tu sais tout avis il faudra que tu
te souviennes qu' il faut se battre pour
la paix et dit bien à nos amis allemands
que nous nous voulons que la paix ça ça
va ça m'est resté gravé et j'ai toujours
cette lettre évidemment la
caractéristique des gens de ma
génération c'est qu'on a connus que la
paix et que l'idée qu'on fasse une
guerre à l'allemagne était simplement
impensable pendant des années des
dizaines des centaines d'années on s'est
bagarré des deux côtés du rhin puis
quand on se bagarrait plus peu un peu on
s'est aperçu qu'on pouvait faire des
choses avec eux quand j'ai lu la lettre
j'ai essayé de la traduire moi je
parlais à peine allemand donc c'est un
peu compliqué mais quand j'ai le mot
frontale vos amis ça c'était facile
si nous savions nous rencontrer nous
comprendre nous parler certainement nous
continuerions à vie en paix on a
aujourd'hui ce qui s'appelle une
citoyenneté européenne qui ne remplace
pas la citoyenneté nationale mais qui
s'ajoute et qui nous donne aussi des
droits le droit de voter aux élections
européennes ou d'être même candidat son
aval la nationalité de l'état membre
dans lequel on se présente ce que ça
c'est quelque chose assez extraordinaire